hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal waren
und willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt und heute machen wir die
zimtschnecken aus angel anaconda das
erste wie schmeckt für 2020
ich habe vor dieses jahr wieder viel
mehr rezepte auszuprobieren 2009 10 ist
mir das irgendwie nicht so gelungen aber
dieses jahr wird es klappen und wir
fangen an mit einem richtigen kracher
weil angel anaconda war meine absolute
lieblingsstadt falls ihr das nicht kennt
weil sie mir schlecht vorstellen kann
aber wenn ihr es nicht kennt es war eine
serie eine kinderserie auf super rtl
damals noch togo gibt es tauge noch auf
jeden fall liebs of togo also togo und
super rtl ist ja irgendwie das gleiche
erstmal ein paar hard facts zu angel
anaconda und falls ich das nicht
aufgefallen ist ich bin natürlich
passend zu angel anaconda angezogen die
deutschsprachige erstausstrahlung war am
27 august 2001 auf super rtl die serie
kam aus kanada und es gibt insgesamt 65
episoden in einer staffel das besondere
bei angel einer condor war dass die
gesicht da quasi fotos waren in schwarz
weiß alles andere war bunt nur die
gesichter waren schwarz weiße fotos ich
weiß nicht warum aber irgendwie liebte
ich diese serie so abgöttisch und diese
tagträume die sima hatte fand ich so
witzig schreibt man gerne in die
kommentare ob die engine anaconda kennt
und ob ihr es geschafft habt und wenn ja
dann gibt diesen video einen daumen nach
oben und vergesst natürlich nicht main
kanal zu abonnieren wenn ihr können als
video verpassen wollte
und auch tun nennt man nur papa papa und
jetzt wo wir alle nostalgisch geworden
sind geht es los so sollten sie später
aussehen und jetzt kommen wir zu den
zutaten würdig sind schnecken brauchen
wir ein würfel frischhefe 50 gramm
weißes gold also zucker 100 milliliter
lauwarmes wasser 500 gramm stinknormales
mailen eine prise sicher haben wir 250 g
weiche butter 2 eier und ich kann cool
julian habe ich jetzt
ich traue mich nicht hast so nicht kaufe
immer nur die hähnlein beste eier die wo
die küken nicht getötet werden
150 gramm brauner zucker und für zins
schnecken braucht man natürlich 24 bit
und 150 gramm puderzucker und fünf
esslöffel sahne natürlich laktosefrei
also natürlich für mich für euch wie ihr
wollt und jetzt kommen wir zu der
zubereitung
wir wissen natürlich jetzt das hefepilz
ist wer meinen kanal noch nicht so lange
kennt ich struggle bis heute damit mir
zu merken ob hierfür ein pils oder
bakterien sind aber ich glaube es ist
ein pilz ich bin mir ziemlich sicher wir
nehmen unseren häfen block und tun ihn
in lauwarmes wasser rein und damit die
hebel was zum futtern hat kommt noch ein
teelöffel zucker ist und man ganz
einfach formulieren dass stellen jetzt
zur seite das mehl kommt nun in unsere
schüsseln gefolgt von unserem restlichen
weißen zucker und einer guten prise salz
und diese trockene party wird jetzt
einmal miteinander verrührt besten geht
das natürlich mit seinem lustigen teigs
aber ihr könnt natürlich auch normale
verwenden aber er war auch was zu lachen
die schneiden 125 gramm von unserer
mutter ab super einfach wenn die so weit
ist und wenn ihr jetzt eine mikrowelle
habt dann könnt ihr sieg
alles easy in der mikrowelle einfach
flüssig machen oder ihr habt keine so
wie ich und macht sie im topf also in
solchen momenten wünsche ich mir
wirklich eine mikrowelle aber irgendwie
dass mich dieses gefühl nicht los dass
mikrowellen schädlich sind ich weiß
nicht ob es so ein fakt ist es ist wie
diese geschichte mit den rahmen nudeln
und ob sie krebserregend sind so
halbwissen was ich irgendwo immer auf
greifen dann mich daran halte mein leben
lang unsere mutter ist jetzt flüssig und
darf in das mail hinein zusammen mit der
hefe zusammen mit den bayern und nun
alles verrühren und ich bin so ein teig
schaber mega praktisch weil da einfach
den ganzen tag man gut mitnimmt so
sollte euer teig dann aussehen schön
fertig wie meine haut dann erinnert ihr
euch dass sie keinen pizzateig macht
sondern sind schnecken und lasst diesen
tag eine stunde ruhen gute nacht mit
einem küchentuch könnt ihr das abdecken
und jetzt an einen warmen ort stellen
wenn ihr zum beispiel eine
fußbodenheizung habt dann legt ihr das
da wo es besonders warm ist oder an eine
normale heizung im winter ist super
sommer auch da könnte es dann raus
spielen oder so keine ahnung muss auf
jeden fall warm sein und in der
zwischenzeit könnt ihr eure wohnung
sauber zaubern
wunderbar ist es nicht einfach ja wo ist
denn diese schüssel ist so warm
willkommen
eine stunde später weg wie viel wie ist
in der tat geworden
was sagt denn das beste kochbuch der
welt was wir als nächstes tun sollen
danach den teig auf einer bemehlten
arbeitsfläche zu einem rechteck
ausrollen ausrollen können wir ein
bisschen mehr drauf war und jetzt
langsam unseren zeiten
ich bin mir nicht so sicher ob man ihn
jetzt kneten sollte aber wir wollen ihn
jetzt einfach aus ist die zeit so
zwei zentimeter dick einzelnen mini
zweite hälfte unserer mutter und unseren
braunen zucker 2 esslöffel zimt nummer
zwei und verrühren jetzt alles
miteinander ich hab gerade eine folge
angel anaconda geschaut und ich hab dann
so eine vermutung warum ich manchmal so
derbe ausdrücke haben hat diese internet
man ua eine um französische dritten
fresse genannt glaubt nicht dass man das
heutzutage noch sein dürfte gerade mal
wieder auf dass der staat für jede
aufgabe am besten geeignet ist
das sieht aus wie diese biscuit creme
von dings dies ihr wisst was ich meine
es riecht sehr sehr gut und das
streichen wir jetzt auf unseren teil und
wir verdecken zwei drittel damit das ist
sünde leute zum glück war ich gleich ins
büro dann kann ich meine zimtschnecken
verteilen dann esse ich nicht alle
alleine und dann schaffe ich es
vielleicht sogar was abzunehmen diesen
monat so sollte das ungefähr aussehen
und das wird jetzt gerollt ist
eigentlich ganz einfach kuku wollen
rollen rollen
dollar kleiner tipp wenn ihr sie nicht
zu holen könnt macht ihr müssen
wasserrädern wie ich lieber auf das
endstück liegt jetzt eure rolle drauf
dann verbindet sich der teig für immer
zusammen das ist unsere rolle und die
schneiden wir jetzt in scheiben und hier
seht ihr die wunderschöne schnecke da
ist die butter zucker zimt mischung ich
hätte vielleicht noch ein bisschen
weiter gehen können aber trotzdem sieht
wunderschön aus finde ich wir sind jetzt
entweder ein backblech benutzen oder
eine backform machen wir natürlich
wieder trick 17 und
magnus backpapier könnt auch was von der
restlichen butter zucker mischung nehmen
und so ein bisschen am dann verteilen
und kleben sie nicht an
und dann bringt die ihre babys ins bett
so hier packe ich jetzt sechs rein
wir brauchen auch ein bisschen platz
weil sie natürlich durch die hefe noch
wachsen werden und ich mag es sie in so
einem geschlossenen raum rhein zu packen
weil sie dann beim backen alle
aneinander deutschen und dann wird der
rand nicht so hart sondern bleibt feucht
kleine form noch einfetten und die drei
restlichen babys rein und diese kleine
stücke packen wir auch sein kann ja
alles gebacken werden und diese dinge
müssen jetzt in den backofen wenn ihr
schlau gewesen wäre hättet ihr den schon
vor gewähren 175 grad
ich muss jetzt warten und jetzt der
backofen nach drei stunden endlich warm
geworden ist kommen unsere sind
schnecken für 25 minuten in den backofen
an wir dürfen wieder warten unsere babys
sehen gut aus und während wir hier so
warten könnt ihr mal in die kommentare
schreiben welches rezept oder welches
gericht aus welcher serie ich unbedingt
mal nachmachen sollen wenn ihr schon
eine konkrete vorstellung gehabt wäre es
schön wenn ihr beschreiben würde wo es
genau vorkommt weil wenn ihr sagt hey
kredite liars lillys dann müsste ich
irgendwie weil sie nicht drei staffeln
pretty little liars gucken will als
pretty little liars
sonst keine ideen habt könnt ihr auch
mal in mein kochbuch reinschauen und was
selber nach machen oder sagen vanessa
hey du hast ja noch gar nicht die
gefüllten waffen röllchen aus titanic
gemacht die würde ich gern mal sehen
worauf es werden definitiv mehr
geschmeckt kommt darauf könnt ihr euch
die habe ich auch noch nicht gemacht
schamlose werbung ende unseren sind
reichen können raus die sind gut auf
juli
sie müssen jetzt erstmal abkühlen glaube
ich hätte sie nicht so breit machen
sollen lieber wie ich im rezeptbuch
geschrieben habt 2 bis 3 cm dick weiß
auch nicht warum ich mich immer an mein
eigenes rezept nicht so hallte es kann
doch diese schwer sein die können es
nach draußen zum abkühlen und in der
zeit kümmern wir uns um den zucker golf
wir brauchen 150 gramm
feinstes puderzucker warum sahne im
rezeptbuch steht fünf esslöffel sahne
aber trotzdem muss man hier vorsichtig
sein und immer wieder rein rühren und
erstmal gucken denn wenn es einmal zu
flüssig ist kinder kommt man nicht
zurück also man kann da mehr puderzucker
rein machen aber dann wird es eine
endlose geschichte ist glaube ich auch
ein bisschen zu viel puder zeuge macht
jetzt meinen normalen ganz klar von den
ganz kleinen schuss so popp
das sollten wir es muss so rauslaufen
aber trotzdem fest jaromir probieren wie
es schmeckt ne hammer so einfach macht
untersuchen jetzt einfach die glasur
draufmachen lecker und das macht ihr
jetzt mit allen wenn ihr so streifen
macht sie das eigentlich ganz schön aus
saada und nun stellen wir uns wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schnecken die
zimtschnecken aus angelo anaconda läutet
der ist erst so weit
auch wenn er so ein bisschen harte kost
an manchen stellen ist er eigentlich
voll weich und dieses und erst noch so
leicht warm und ok also das echt süß
aber der teig ist super für luftig und
hat aus und so eine harte kruste und
diese zucker zimt butter mischung da
drin
es schmeckt richtig lecker also um die
frage zu beantworten die zimtschnecken
aus ein schneller konter schmecken
extrem lecker leicht warm schmecken sie
glaube ich am besten absolute empfehlung
meine augen im kopf drin also und es ist
nicht cool wenn man gäste hat oder so
ein frühstücksbrunch machten sonja
wollte eine zimtschnecken ich selbst
gemacht ich hoffe natürlich wie immer
euch hat die folge gefallen und wenn ja
dann zeigt es mir unbedingt mit einem
daumen nach oben abonniert main kanal
verziert noch nicht gemacht habt und
dann würde ich sagen sehen wir uns beim
nächsten video chats eure virgil
anaconda der war schlecht nach ganz
lieber an euch bis nicht mal